[Music]
on this monday night the massacre in
buffalo new york
the families of victims described the
heartache he
took away my mother and the heroism he
helped so many people in his community
it's unreal plus how white supremacy is
on the rise even though
they may not have pulled the trigger
they did load the gun
for this young white supremacy
new progress in pushing back russian
forces
ukraine's latest victory plus potential
hurdles to sweden and finland joining
nato
and outsourcing objections i was a
little bit underwhelmed concerns about
private companies processing canada's
visa applications
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin in buffalo new york and the
aftermath of the murder of 10 people in
a targeted shooting at a grocery store
the accused gunman an 18 year old is
alleged to have driven more than 300
kilometers too according to the mayor of
buffalo use a high-powered rifle to kill
as many black people as possible
inspired by white supremacist ideology
survivors and loved ones are trying to
find a place for their grief unable to
comprehend the horrific racist hate
crime
all 10 of those killed were black
mothers fathers grandparents aged 32 to
86. their lives ended while they were
out doing their grocery shopping on a
spring afternoon
they were pulled into uh as if you when
it happens at least my experience you
feel like you're pulling a little black
hole inside your chest and
everything everything you can't
and it's hard
police say the gunman was heavily armed
wearing tactical gear and had made a
meticulous plan before he arrived one
piece of evidence police are examining
is a document purportedly written by the
gunman who describes himself as a
fascist a white supremacist and an
anti-semite police say he is on suicide
watch tonight we have comprehensive
coverage beginning with jackson prosco
in buffalo
in this corner of east buffalo almost
everyone knows someone who was there
being a dad causing his life being a
black dad
cost him his life melanie charles is a
family friend of andre mcneil he was
picking up a surprise birthday cake for
his three-year-old son when he was shot
and killed inside the tops market our
men don't get a lot of credit
for being fathers and being active and
being there and he literally gave his
life to be there for his little boy
crystal pino's friend and next door
neighbor roberta drury is the youngest
victim of the attack just 32 years old
the two had planned to meet for coffee
saturday after roberto went for
groceries i was on the phone with her at
2 15 by 2
40 she was gone she was just amazing she
didn't deserve any of this
no one did no one did
[Music]
this is so difficult overwhelmed by
grief the family of 86 year old ruth
whitfield found the strength to tell her
story a woman loved a life well lived
taken by an act of pure hate
he
took away my mother
and my best friend how dare you
how dare you
this needs to be fixed
a-s-a-p
ruth had stopped at the tops market
after her daily visit to a long-term
care home to see her husband of 68 years
garnell
the family hasn't found the words to
tell him why the love of his life can't
come to see him anymore we're angry
we're mad
this shouldn't have happened the callous
and calculated attack struck so deeply
because it was targeted at the heart of
this predominantly black neighborhood
tops as the only grocery store in the
area a source of food and opportunity
i was broken like i didn't know if these
kids were
all right if they were in there if they
were in there on the floor four of
teacher stevo johnson's students were
working inside the store at the time of
the attack they all survived their young
lives forever changed
so where do people go from here
like
it's
unspeakable there is no moving on when
no place feels safe and when hate seems
to have no limits
the families of the victims are deeply
committed to making sure that nothing
like this can ever happen again they've
hired famed civil rights attorney ben
crump to help go after those who spread
the ideology of white supremacy those
who may have helped radicalize the
shooter speaking today crump called this
a clear act of domestic terrorism and
donna he says this should be treated the
same way as any other terrorist attack
in america all right and jackson there
was some talk today about
concerns about threats being made to
people in buffalo threats being called
into other businesses what more can you
tell us about that
police say they've arrested a man who
phoned in threats to at least two other
businesses referencing what happened
here at the supermarket speaking to
people all day long they say they're
deeply concerned by what they're seeing
unfolded and the closure of these
businesses because it's further
victimization of their community and
leaves them feeling that there is no
place that is truly safe anymore donna
all right jackson in buffalo tonight
thanks one of the reporters who headed
to buffalo as soon as we got word of the
shooting is global's sean o'shea joins
me now sean you've covered other mass
shootings i know and we've led the
newscast with them so many times it
feels like america is destined to just
keep repeating this
where are people in buffalo going with
their grief
donna what struck me was when we crossed
the peace bridge into buffalo from
toronto and something happened that had
never happened before got to the border
guard and gave my passport and she asked
what we're coming to do and as soon as i
told the border guard while we were here
she went into a discussion with me for
five minutes and it was almost like i
was a therapist for the border guard and
my cameraman was right behind she didn't
even ask him for his passport we were
right through but people wanted to talk
about it
and since we got here yesterday early
yesterday morning people in this
community which is called cold spring
it's in east buffalo it's a
predominantly african-american community
people have wanted to talk about it
there were prayers yesterday and today
lots of people hugging lots of people
bringing you know memorial
flowers those kinds of things which we
see at other mass shootings but the
difference for me here is that this is
racially motivated that's not the case
at many other mass shootings and so
people i think here have a feeling that
this is different and they were really
targeted here i want to play just a
couple of comments from the many that uh
many people we spoke to today
this landed on our doorstep
and it's evil it's hateful
and it's just it's just corrupt
to do what's necessary to keep us to the
point of getting past this getting past
this whole thing it only brought us
together strongly
sean you posted a clip on twitter of one
man who told you things will never be
the same that people will always be
looking over their shoulders is there a
sense that racism and white supremacy is
on the rise
i get that sense here donna um that that
idea that it won't be the same there was
another woman who told me that she'd
never be able to send one of her
children her teenage children to the
grocery store imagine that not feeling
like you could safely send somebody to
buy groceries and this is the only
grocery store in this community what a
terrible feeling and many people have
that feeling and they're sharing that
feeling and this is how people here feel
right now donna all right shawn o'shea
in buffalo new york thanks
buffalo is just a short drive over the
canadian border and though we like to
think of ourselves as kinder and gentler
than the u.s we have mass shootings and
racism here too it was only five years
ago that a gunman opened fire inside a
quebec city mosque killing six people 11
people died in toronto in 2018 in a van
attack motivated by incel ideology
abigail beeman on how canada's
intelligence agency is tracking the rise
in domestic extremism
heartbreaking scenes out of buffalo have
shaken many canadians but there is hate
here too
26 people killed and 40 wounded on
canadian soil due to ideologically
motivated violent extremism since 2014
according to the most recent csis report
right-wing extremism and terrorism is an
international
movement canada is far far better than
any other context
but i mean you know we still have trash
in our yard as well this is the really
frightening thing and i think surprising
thing is that proportionately if we just
talk about the number of groups it's
very similar to the us barbara perry's
research has identified 300 active
right-wing hate groups in canada and she
says there are likely tens of thousands
more people drawn to the movement
without being part of a group
cesas has been devoting more resources
to the threat of violent extremism the
combination of major disruptive events
like the pandemic
the ever-increasing influence of social
media and the spreads of conspiracy
theories has created an environment
right for exploitation by influencers
and extremists the spy agency's head was
recently testifying at a parliamentary
committee about the convoy in ottawa
with a number of individuals known to
ceases conservative michelle rempel
garner called out one of the convoy
leaders currently in custody pat king
condemning him on twitter for espousing
the great replacement theory and calling
others to do the same it's a form of
hate it has no basis in reality it's
conspiratorial the great replacement
theory is believed to be a motive in the
buffalo shooting a racist and
anti-semitic conspiracy theory about a
plot to replace white people spearheaded
by jews
in canada in 2020 jews were the biggest
target of hate crimes against religious
minorities canada's got to
look at hate online and how we can
better regulate that every time there's
a tragedy like this you you sort of
think could we have done it could we
have done it faster but it's also
important to do it right while minister
omar algabra says hate needs to be taken
more seriously than ever before
including by politicians whenever comes
time to condemn such a mass shooting
everybody comes rallies around and
condemning it
but ignore the fact that some leaders
have come close to
looking like they if they're not
endorsing it that they're tolerating it
or looking the other way abigail beeman
global news ottawa
sweden's prime minister formally
announced to date wants to join nato and
russia's president says while that does
not threaten moscow directly any
expansion of military infrastructure
would trigger a response from the
kremlin and in ukraine the defense
ministry now says more than 200 soldiers
are leaving the as of stalled steel
plant in mariopol they'll be taken to
russian territory and the plan is to
exchange them with russian military
prisoners and then be returned home as
well troops defending the second largest
city harkeev say they've pushed russian
forces all the way back to the border
with russia redmond shannon reports
a trek to the edge of ukraine where it
appears borders are being restored this
video released by ukraine's defense
ministry claims to show troops planting
a boundary marker at the country's
russian border in harki region
president vladimir zelinsky thanks the
soldiers who have won back the territory
north of ukraine's second city a further
indication that russia is being forced
back
but the kremlin's attention is also
being diverted westward a day after
finland sweden formally confirmed its
intention to join nato leaving behind
200 years of neutrality in direct
response to russia's invasion of ukraine
as a nato member sweden would not only
strengthen its own security but also
contribute to enhanced security in the
baltic sea region
canada's foreign minister melanie jolie
met with european union foreign
ministers monday she says there is
cross-party support for canada to
quickly approve finland and sweden's
accession to nato the prime minister is
a very seized of the matter and we think
that it could take days for canada so
that's why we want to be one of the
first countries to do so
it may not be so simple in turkey it
wants both nordic nations to end their
support for the pkk kurdistan workers
party turkey regards the kurdish
separatist group as a terrorist
organization as does canada and other
allies
in moscow vladimir putin hosted a
meeting of nato's russian-led equivalent
the collective security treaty
organization it is a club of six former
soviet nations
putin told his counterparts the proposed
nato enlargement poses no threat to
their alliance but he warned that any
new nato infrastructure closer to russia
would provoke a response redmond shannon
global news london
visa processing problems coming up
complaints the federal government is
outsourcing work
[Music]
getting ukrainian refugees to canada has
magnified long-standing problems with
how canada processes visas those
applying for canadian visas say they're
faced with lengthy delays ill-informed
staff and a dysfunctional booking portal
as david aiken explains the main problem
seems to be a shift to a privatized
service
ottawa has been outsourcing its visa
application process for more than a
decade from a few centers in india in
2007 to today with more than 160
processing centers in more than 100
countries around the world
they are all run by a for-profit company
called vfs global it is headquartered in
dubai but it's owned by a swedish
investment firm its current contract
with canada is worth more than 300
million dollars and it has similar visa
processing contracts with dozens of
other countries so when you actually
look at the impact on the system it
allows us to
potentially welcome thousands and
thousands of more people to canada than
otherwise would be the case but the
ukraine crisis has opened up some cracks
in the outsourcing system canada relies
on with complaints about service levels
long lineups and delays conservative mp
jasran hallan toured a vfs global center
during a recent trip to europe i saw the
system there myself
i was a little bit underwhelmed at how
much better canada can be doing today
but immigration minister sean fraser
says the humanitarian crisis like the
one in ukraine is proving the worth of
canada's decision to outsource last
month vfs global opened up what it
called pop-up visa processing centers on
ukraine's border to deal with the surge
of applicants on behalf of its clients
including canada and when you have the
opportunity to use either pop-up or
existing visa application centers in
addition to permanent locations
for for local missions you really can
respond to humanitarian crises more
effectively ndp immigration critic jenny
kwon has long worried about the privacy
implications for those who used
outsourced visa application centers well
to be very honest with you i don't like
the idea at all
with visa application centers there's a
lot of sensitive information that goes
out our main concern is that we should
be bringing things back to canada
they're bringing back more to home and
have more control over of course given
the rise of cyber security but it looks
like ottawa is going in the opposite
direction the government is looking at
plans to boost its reliance on these
outsourced visa application centers and
increase the services they provide
david aiken global news ottawa
ahead dangerous conspiracy theories
breeding a new generation of white
supremacists
even though
they may not have pulled the trigger
they did load the gun
for this young white supremacist
that is ben crump he's the lawyer for
one of the people killed by the gunman
in buffalo he named what he called
accomplices to the mass murder the
right-wing pundits the websites and the
cable news hosts who he says curate and
inspire the hate and espouse the
baseless great replacement theory the
notion that white americans are being
replaced with immigrants and people of
color eric sorenson explains how that
racist theory has moved into the
mainstream
a mass killing inspired by hate is sadly
nothing new one alleged gunman espoused
white supremacist rhetoric against an
hispanic invasion before a massacre in
el paso texas another warned of a jewish
invasion before the synagogue shooting
in pittsburgh and now white replacement
theory was cited by the alleged shooter
of black americans in buffalo what is
new and disturbing is the growing
embrace of that conspiracy in the u.s
that white culture and white supremacy
are being replaced by the power of
immigrants and other minorities that's
what's happening actually let's just say
it that's true it's a message heard
today on mainstream media i have less
political power because they're
importing a brand new electorate why
should i sit back and take that new
york's governor says that rhetoric is
selling us versus them the them
the immigrants
the jews the blacks are coming after us
the white people in this country some
critics say president trump's tolerance
for the fringe right was a springboard
for white grievance this is not a
right-wing problem
he
became
sort of a mouthpiece for a lot of these
fringe right-wing movements that have
gradually over time now become much more
embraced by people who are working in
congress people in popular media outlets
like tucker carlson the lawyer for one
buffalo family says victims must use the
law to hold those responsible for
providing a platform for racial hatred
the people who inspired hate on websites
and internet services and cable news
stations
those people who radicalize
these young people
the killing of muslims at a mosque in
quebec in 2017 and the vehicle killing
of a muslim family in london ontario
last year show this country is not
immune those pieces are absolutely here
in the canadian context the fear of the
other
overcoming us
numerically and and politically and
socially barbara perry says in this
country just as the fbi says in the u.s
the greatest domestic terror threat
today is homegrown racial hatred buffalo
apparently the latest example eric
sorensen global news toronto
next the security guard who died trying
to save lives
it's impossible to say how each one of
us would react if faced with a heavily
armed gunman intent on killing in
buffalo a security guard in that grocery
store didn't hesitate retired police
officer aaron salter jr tried to stop
the gunman head on before paying the
ultimate price
mike charley reports
aaron salter jr wore many hats in his
life retired police officer substitute
teacher but one of his true passions was
science he built a lab in his garage
where he spent countless hours working
to develop an engine that could run on
water it's not running off of gas fuels
no there's no gas here
no no
sadly for all he was in life the world
is learning his story because of the
courage he displayed doing his job
protecting his community
working security at the tops grocery
store salter engaged the shooter who was
heavily protected by body armor we have
evidence that he struck him at least one
time and that unfortunately had no
effect not everyone would have made the
same choice to run towards gunfire and
with his experience 30 years on the
buffalo police force he had to have
guessed the shooter had an assault rifle
yet salter tried ultimately in vain to
save the lives of others aaron was
i mean a great individual and i know he
in his heart he'd want to save as many
people as he could
and i it didn't surprise me to hear that
he engaged the guy right away that tried
to stop him salter retired from the
buffalo police force in 2018 and by all
accounts he didn't need this job at tops
working security surviving a job in law
enforcement and making retirement
is a big deal for you personally and for
your family because they expect you know
you can kind of ride it out now and
enjoy your life but salter chose to
continue serving his community because
he believed he could make it better now
his former colleagues are trying to get
him reinstated into that police force
for a single day so his city can honor
him with the formal police funeral they
say he deserves
microlight global news
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen we leave you
tonight with some of the tributes and
the memorials outside the grocery store
in buffalo
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you